hi this is presh talwalkar let's discuss
a math problem from the movie little man
tate
the problem is you need to find a number
that when divided by the product of its
digits you get an answer of 3 and when
you add 18 to the number the digits of
the number are reversed
the problem is difficult to set up
because it involves the actual digits in
the number
so to figure out how we can do this
we'll do a refresher
when you have the number 12
that really means 10 times 1 plus 2
and if you have the number 58 that means
10 times 5 plus 8.
so in general if you have a number xy in
the decimal system that's 10 times x
plus y
we can use this to set up the first
problem that when you take the number
and divide it by its product of the
digits you get the quotient of 3.
the other condition is when you add 18
to the number you reverse the digits x
and y
this implies that y equals x plus 2
which we're going to substitute into our
other condition
we end up with a quadratic equation
which we can factor out
and at this point we can get to the
solution of x equals minus 1 3 or x
equals 2. obviously the digits have to
be positive so we have x equals 2.
we substitute that back in to find y
equals 4 and we have the answer of 24
we can look at the problem again and
we'll verify that this indeed is a
solution when we divide it by the
product of the digits we get 3 and when
we add 18 the digits are reversed please
subscribe to my channel
you can support me on patreon
you can catch me on my blog
binderdecisions on twitter at
preshtalocker
and you can get my books and amazon